une ambiance à l'américaine
[Musique]
pour accueillir en super héros le
président candidat
ça pousse à mettre en ligne
merci d'être venus des quatre coins du
pays
venus par milliers scandait en boucle
des slogans
emmanuel macron laura d'abord défilé ce
qu'il accomplit ses cinq dernières
années comme il dit une cavalcade de
progrès l'inégalité en matière il a
présenté ses priorités s'il devait
rester à l'elysée
emmanuel macron devant ses adversaires
dans les sondages en partie grâce à son
action en tant que chef d'état au coeur
de la diplomatie internationale pour
tenter d'arrêter la guerre en ukraine
certains aujourd'hui je le disais bon
board à quelques heures de part et
d'autres voudraient nous ramenait en
france des amis en arrière une flèche
décochée vers l'extrême droite dont il
dénonce la banalisation et en
particulier vers marine le pen qui se
présente comme la présidente du
quotidien et du pouvoir d'achat l'une
des grandes préoccupations des français
emmanuel macron promet d'en faire encore
plus pour aider les ménages les
travailleurs jeux wii
de viser l'objectif du plein emploi
comme en réponse à la candidate du
rassemblement national marine le pen qui
pourrait causer la surprise au deuxième
tour à l'en croire les récents sondages
sur l'éventualité d'un duel avec le
président sortant je pense que c'est un
vrai danger je pense que il a eu raison
aujourd'hui de dire que rien n'est gagné
rien n'est fait faut pas avoir d'
arrogance par rapport aux résultats de
ces élections emmanuel macron qui refuse
tout débat avant le premier tour de
scrutin a tardé à défendre sa
candidature
ce premier et seul grand rassemblement
pour convaincre les français n'arrivent
c'est pas trop tard non au contraire ce
que l'on entre dans le money time
justement là on est à on est à une
semaine du premier tour un peu moins
d'une semaine donc voilà il faut
justement tout donné la ce a redonné un
gain un gain d'énergie à tout le monde
pour la dernière semaine de campagne
emmanuel macron veut que les français
soient derrière lui notamment ceux de la
gauche qu'il courtise avec des mesures
sociales il veut les voir agir l'ivoire
bâtir les voir lutter contre le danger
extrémistes et contre le repli sur soi
un appel à la mobilisation
alors qu'il est en léger recul dans les
sondages ici annick bureaud radio canada
barry